The Joe Rogan Experience you're an
Applebee's guy I love Applebee's really
what's what's it about Applebee's I love
the neighborhood man
I loved it the atmosphere I love the
atmosphere I love I love the drink they
give you that comes with a gummy shark
which one's that I don't know what it's
called one of them signature cocktails
yeah but it's so good and they have a
special Mountain Dew at Applebee's they
do yeah it's special yeah it's special
it's only um Applebee's what's this
special you looking for another one of
those I got this one right here
it's uh it's like uh it's like a
raspberry flavor I think it's called
like space
dark berry bash it's called actually
Nasa uses orange filters on Mars Bash
I swear to God check that [__] out look
into it they might I think what Jamie's
saying about color correction though is
accurate yeah that's what I was just
looking in the photos they all come
black and white I think right it's I
think the thing is that they're just
getting data
they're getting data and that data has
to be interpreted into an image and it's
it's a lot more complicated than like
you taking a picture on your iPhone and
texting it to me and I get it and it's
in Full Resolution look up Mars look up
Mars copy and paste look up NASA copy
and paste
coffee let's see if this works
it's Ed Mars for a buzzword what do you
think about all this UFO disclosure [__]
are you paying attention to it yes sir
yeah
it's it's I think it's pretty cool
that's pretty interesting right yeah you
know what's interesting like how little
people seem to care
I know but it's interesting that like
there wasn't like some moment where
people like were like holy [__] aliens
are real there's nothing that's coming
you think I think it's good because this
slow trickle it's going to be we just
accept it well they try to normalize it
with like yeah
like War of the Worlds which is like the
world or Battle of uh Los Angeles and
[__] like that that was a real [__]
thing that happened
the pictures of battle Los Angeles uh is
crazy what happened exactly there's this
big
object in the sky and we're shooting
machine guns at it we got different
spotlights this is like in the 50s Maybe
there's this photo look at this [__]
wow so we're putting [__] rounds on
this [__] thing spotlights on this
thing in this look at the rounds right
but what is it what is it that they see
that's weird all you can see is
spotlights 1947 it says in the corner
boy that looks like a [__] Flying
Saucer look at them look at in the
middle and look at but those things
around it those are [__] like Ma
deuce rounds
like they're shooting at this [__]
thing they don't know what it is well
you know that there's a there's a famous
story uh from the Soviet Union that
these guys shot at a uh UFO and it
turned them into stone
is it true I don't know the CIA
investigated it here I'll send it to you
Jamie because I sent it to Jeremy
Corbell that's what I asked him [__] I
should have had links Jamie God damn it
well this is the only link I have it's
uh CIA UFO turned into stuff you're
definitely on a watch list yeah so
there's a there's literally like a CIA
document about it that these guys
supposedly
um shot at a low-flying spaceship look
at according to the KGB materials a
quite low-flying spaceship in the shape
of a saucer appeared above a military
unit that was conducting routine
training Maneuvers for unknown reasons
somebody unexpectedly launched a
surface-to-air missile and hit the UFO
it fell to Earth not far away and five
short humanoids with large heads and
large black eyes emerged from it it is
stated in the testimonies by the two
soldiers who remained alive that after
freeing themselves from the debris the
aliens came close together and then
merged into a single object that
acquired a spherical shape that object
began to buzz and hiss sharply and then
became brilliant white in a few seconds
the Spheres grew much bigger and
exploded by flaring up with an extremely
bright light at that very instant 23
soldiers who had watched the phenomenon
turned into stone polls polls yeah only
two soldiers who stood in the shade and
were less exposed to the Luminous
explosion survived no [__] the KGB
report goes on to say that the remains
of the UFO and the Petrified soldiers
were transferred to a secret scientific
research institution near Moscow
Specialists assumed that a source of
energy that is still unknown to
earthlings instantly changed the
structure of the soldiers living
organisms having transformed it into a
substance whose molecular composition is
no different from that of limestone
oh it turned them into limestone turned
literally into limestone and this is a
CA CIA paperwork well this is you know
they're reading from a KGB file right so
it's it's just go to the very bottom and
then again Jamie at the very bottom is
one of the things that says the CI
representative stated if the kg by B
file corresponds to reality this is an
extremely menacing case the aliens
possess such weapons and technology that
go beyond all our assumptions they can
stand up for themselves if attacked
the other thing is they're saying if the
the file corresponds to reality that
means there's if this is real they're
tough
yeah they they can [__] with you what
year was this released
I don't know source is a newspaper 1991
93 93. so there you know there's all
these disclosures that are going on
right now and they're very very
fascinating because it's hard to know
what's true and what's not true but it's
interesting that they're talking about
it but no one showed me anything yet I'm
waiting for them to show me things I've
seen some things already like those
videos that they took off the uh the the
FLIR video in the go fast video and
these these videos of these things with
these jet pirate fighter pilots are
trying to track this thing it's like
zipping across the sky and they're like
what the [__] is that I've seen a few of
those I've seen talked to two different
fighter pilots that have had encounters
and they're all in they're all in I I
think there's a real thing going on what
that real thing is is what would is
what's confusing to me I think some of
it has to be ours
I think some of it has to be like super
Advanced drone technology that we don't
want everyone knowing about and it's
probably some Black Ops [__] but I don't
think that's all of it I think it's also
possible that we've been visited
it just makes sense it just it sounds so
stupid that's part of the problem of
even talking about it because it sounds
dumb because there's no evidence so you
have to believe in something where
there's no evidence of it other than
like some blurry photographs
but but then when you just think about
the size of the universe itself and the
fact that we exist we exist here on this
planet we're real we know we're real
what if it's [__] a Martha or
whatever and they're from [__] the
center of the earth in the holes in the
polar the poles or whatever north and
south and
that's where the holes are and that's
why uh Google Maps blocks it all out and
all that [__] well that would be a great
Theory before cell phones like that but
it's not there you still can't see it
maybe you can with satellites and also
flight patterns
like the people that copy and paste but
I know who doesn't think the world is
flat
Pilots true or anyone who's better than
airplanes they fly around these
[__] they know they know where
they have to go they know the flight
patterns and you look at it yeah you
look at it also by the way everything's
round go out in the [__] sky and look
at Mars look at Jupiter get a telescope
look at all the stars notice how
everything's around seems like there's a
pattern going on yeah why would this be
different this ass is around yeah
oh I don't know it's it's so weird man
it I don't know and you're talking about
the oh [__] moment I think we've been so
like normalized to it like E.T all this
[__] growing up watching this [__] to
where it's like yeah no [__] everyone no
matter what the surveys say or anything
everyone
thinks there's like
something going on everyone yeah it had
there's a few people that still are very
incredulous
Elon believe it or not is incredulous he
he's famously said if the aliens are
really they sure are subtle
they're very excited a Bigfoot subtle
too
doesn't mean he's not an
interdimensional being that could
teleport it well knows where the cameras
are
he's an omniscient being he shuts down
Bigfoot is just Jesus Christ full beard
all over he's just Woods Jesus
yeah that's what he is y'all see in the
woods Jesus mythical creature
looking out for Humanity our brothers
and sisters they need our help he's a
benevolent kind being he's got a big
heart